hey how's it going everybody Aaron
Sampson here with Spencer Mulder how's
it going everybody I saw the chat
somebody's like Rob's fighting any
excuse to play Battlefield he is but
it's gonna be us playing today
um Battlefield one is available for just
about everybody starting tomorrow
but we've been playing it for about a
week now uh no I've early enlistment and
all that fun Jazz it's been so much fun
and this game is really going to be
amazing we're going to show you some
amazing Parts here uh not only more
gameplay we're going to show you some
pretty uh early tips to help you guys
get a jump start on the competition so
uh you ready to jump into this thing
yeah so the focus of our stream today uh
we've been playing for about a week
Spencer's been playing a lot of assault
I've been playing a lot of support a
little bit of scout
um and I got a lot of medic yeah so we
got a lot of medic oh yeah so between us
we've played most of the classes we've
all done done a lot of vehicle Warfare
and we wanted to basically show people
kind of tips and tricks and we will take
questions
um anything you want to know we've been
compiling lists of interesting things
the game doesn't tell you
um I'll start off with with one while
you're loading up here the bayonet
um should you or should you not have a
bayonet on your rifle the game doesn't
really make that super clear
I definitely recommend having a bayonet
on the gun I mean yeah there has been
occasions where people have said if you
take the bayonet off you're actually
able to bring your rifle up faster to
your shoulder it doesn't really affect
accuracy though and personally I would
rather have a bayonet as that extra
melee opportunity because I can't tell
how many times where I've shot at a guy
took out his buddies but another guy
showed up I'm out of ammo what do you do
you charge Adam and you pay an atom and
that's so satisfying to do that so the
interesting thing about that charge is
that if there's an elite class on the
field the bayonet charge is the only
thing that can one hit kill them right
um and I actually got killed earlier
today with the flamethrower Trooper a
guy a guy charged through my Flames with
a Bayonet and stab me and actually for
the uh the Sentry kit when they have the
armor on the front you want to mail them
in the back because that's that's where
they're vulnerable I've actually had
people try to melee me in the front
while I'm playing as the kit and you're
just they're just hitting armor right
you know one shot they're dead so always
remember if you see an armor kit wait
for them to pass you and then try to ban
at them in the back that's the best way
to take them out fast so in the chat
sneaky saying you ads faster without the
bayonet um that's true you you ads
faster from a run so I would actually
say that if you are not finding yourself
bayonetting people frequently in my
opinion you're hurting yourself if you
have the bayonet on the gun if you're
making the vast majority of your kills
shooting people with very few bayonet
kills in between you're just slowing
down your ability to bring up your
weapon from a Sprint every single time
you sprint
so it depends like if you're a big
bayonet player yes but if you're not
someone who Bandits very often you
should probably just go ahead and pull
that off all your weapons yeah and you
are as you say before you are vulnerable
after that charge I know some people use
the charge just to get from point A to
point B quicker because it is a lot
faster than your Sprint but when you're
out of breath you actually are very
vulnerable not only to enemy fire but
also choose it aiming down your sights
as well so let's see if we can load up
in here you also saved up one of the new
battle packs
yeah we're gonna open up that probably
in the next
playing the next match but yeah I know
again one of the new battle packs been
saving up a lot on that because they
actually have three different Battle
Packs than this so we'll open that just
a moment so just real quick for those
just joining us who may not be familiar
with operations this is their
it's kind of like their new Rush
Conquest mode
it is amazing though this mode yes so
basically how this works is that you
have battle sections and in each battle
section there's two to three flags and
the object of this is to obviously the
attackers to capture the flags and
Defenders to hold them off and it's this
is probably some of the most intense
fighting I've ever seen in a Battlefield
game to date I mean it really is intense
so here we are here's my assault class
and as you can see I pretty much had
almost every single gun unlocked the gun
I have attached right now is the model
10A Hunter this shotgun I kid you not I
think is one of my favorite shotguns in
the game and easily one of the most
powerful and also too is that Gadget
wise I have an at rocket gun which you
used a lot this gun is great for taking
out infantry but more importantly he's
actually great for taking out uh armored
vehicles anything out there that's on
Wheels it's really great to use and
combine that with your anti-tank grenade
you're just gonna destroy Vehicles left
and right so it's a great combo
combination to mix in here the other
thing I like to do with the at launcher
when they're not vehicles on the map is
I just use it as my fight elephant gun
slash sniper rifle yeah and don't
hesitate to use it to remove other
players particularly
um Scout players oh hello all right get
in there Spencer do you work with that
shotgun that has a range of what like 20
feet yeah pretty much but I'm still
gonna try to see if I can flank these
guys oh this is bad this is a wide open
area
see if we try to get across here
one of the interesting things is so the
assault class pretty much is the
engineer class they
like the first time we started playing
this game we thought that they had taken
the engineer and split him up into the
pilot and the tanker but the truth is
they really added the pilot in the
tanker and the Cavalry gentleman
um they just handed all of the things
that destroyed tanks to the assault
class so the assault class has the
launcher the assault class has the
dynamite and the assault class has the
mines in my opinion they should probably
split those up between other classes but
for now
the assault class kind of is the
engineer plus he has the SMG so he
pretty much just is the engineer and
he's the guy you should expect to use
against Vehicles when you load them up
speaking of vehicles we got one right up
here
Joshua is asking what is the hellfighter
M1911
and the hellfighter in 1911 is actually
a pre-order it's the uh it's basically
the cousin to the starting pistol you
have which is the I thought it was the
1911 so the Hellfire is a little more
powerful it's this gun right here as you
can see it's all pimped out it's all
gold well it was did you feel like any
of the pre-order weapons
were in any way different or better I
know you almost recommended one in a
video that we made
you almost nope got him oh
okay I thought that was a butt spawn
there for a second but I think he came
out of the tank guy right here too I
think I think I've definitely found some
inconsistencies in that um dangerous
spawn so I think they started it maybe
in a hard line where you couldn't spawn
on somebody Under Fire
I've been locked out of dangerous
spawning but I've also shot a man and
had somebody butt spawned
while I was damned that thing has some
good range yeah I love this gun as I
said this is a you get this actually you
get the the different versions of this
gun when you reach assault rank two
that's the personal one not the overall
rank for your character and then when
you get to assault rank three that's
when you get it so can you break it down
real quick for people how do you
actually buy guns in this game because
it's not the most straightforward
process at first
so you get guns in this game by
unlocking war bonds that you get every
time you rank up now when you first rank
up you get War bun did we get them yeah
we got them uh oh no I'm still alive we
get war bonds every time you rank up but
when you first start off in the game
you're gonna earn around I'd say 62 I
think 100 war bonds per Rank and then
when you get to past Rank 10 that's when
the game starts to give you a lot more
oh what here's the guy right
you get uh I believe 160 after you pass
Rank 10 and it continues to go up from
there I mean there was a time where I
had over 680 war bonds now you're
thinking yourself oh man you could buy
every gun in the game with that but to
be honest I think a pistol cost 150 a
good gun costs about 200 to 300
depending upon what it is so you
actually go through those war bonds
pretty quick and that's actually not
counting the gadgets that it will cost
you to buy in this game as well so you
made a video earlier about kind of what
weapons you suggested people buy first
just because of that really slow rate of
accrual of war bonds in the beginning
now the other thing is the experience
that leads you to get the war bonds is
based on these what are they metals or
trophies
and unlike in Battlefield 3 and 4
they're not all active at once you
actually have to pick one of them to be
active and work on that one at a time
yeah so you have to work on those you
take your time
how did you oh no I'm gonna do that here
that's gonna get me
that was great and that is uh I have two
Health that is Spencer's endorsement of
which shotgun is this again this is the
m oh God this is a model 10 a hunter the
model 10A Hunter shotgun yes you will
and I know a lot of people are thinking
oh this thing's op as hell well to be
honest with you this was close range to
medium range fighting but long range
this gun's not that great I mean it's a
shotgun so bear that in mind but for
maps like this I would not pick any
other shotgun above this so this is
definitely worth moving forward with if
you plan to play as assault for quite a
while this is the gun to get so we have
some questions in the chat how different
is this from the beta uh so to be honest
with you the beta we didn't get to
experiment with many of these guns to
cook in the beta however I noticed that
the explosives the explosives are a lot
more powerful here and do more damage
than they did in the beta for example
the rifle grenade that you get for the
medic I feel they can do more damage oh
you can blow through those Walls by the
way all these walls are closed no
explosive I've I don't I've only died
once yet so I have no I would say the
biggest difference from the beta are the
are like literally just the the variety
in the maps I thought the beta Maps felt
very similar
um and once you get into the full game
you have type you have tight Urban
fights you have large city fights you
have Chateau fights you have fights that
take place in the countryside you have
like honest to goodness trench warfare I
just think the full release as opposed
to the beta
gives you
a huge variety of maps and experiences
that I did not experience like Sinai
desert to me
was cool for a while but then I got
buried samey oh no this is gonna get me
this is so good yeah it's gonna get me
oh I got an assistant
okay so that um talked a little bit
about war bonds
um how you get them oh I'm back
the fact that you have to select your
your tracked Metals in order to earn
more XP to get your levels in your war
bonds
um let's talk about the new battle crate
system yeah so the battlecrate system
what they've done here is that you can
get skins and you can get puzzle pieces
for special melee weapons so far oh man
that sucks for that guy uh you get melee
pieces for certain characters for
certain guns sorry that depending upon
what they are you can scrap them and
gain more points to get more battle
packs now Battle Packs
to me personally they're really cool but
uh you really want to try to get your
way towards getting those puzzle pieces
to unlock really great melee weapon
legendary melee weapons I know they have
one that's a club that spikes in it we
don't know if they're great we just know
that they look different I'm not
convinced that that's uh I'm not
convinced it's like a big draw yet we'll
see
I mean we'll we'll see but I I really
would like to give those a whirl oh we
got them
that was great you won the war yeah you
could win the war with that shotgun
alone
yeah so that's the model A10 Hunter for
the assault class you just saw right
there in action and uh when when do you
unlock that or when can you purchase it
you can get the variants at assault
Class 2 and I think the final version
you can get at assault uh assault rank
three I believe well we can check that
but yeah no it's it's so worth it it's
so good but there also are guns that
working your way up there you should try
and mess with that are pretty good as
well shotgun wise that's one thing too
about the assault class I feel like the
shot the assault class got way too many
shotguns in this game I mean I like the
different variants of shotguns but it
would have been nice for them to kind of
explore further into the machine gun
machine gun area but you know what can
you do
also want to give a shout out to uh
people watching on Twitch as well
um we're doing a battlefield 1 tips and
tricks stream we've been playing this
game for about a week now so if you guys
have any questions we'd be happy to
answer them otherwise we'll just drop
knowledge as we go
um
Spencer's played a lot of assaults he's
also played a lot of medic uh I've
played a lot of support and some Scout
um so we can talk about kind of the
differences in their gadgets over the
years what how their gadgets are working
now you know one of the most fun gadgets
are right now and I'm not even gonna say
that it's useful
but um the Scout has a decoys which are
hilarious they're like these heads on a
spike
they're like crash head dummies yeah
like dummies on a spike and you can put
them up and if they get shot they spot
the person who shot them but they spot
like a player so
when you are getting into scat on Scout
fights it's hilarious to put up a couple
dummy heads and watch them get dropped
and then see exactly where the guy was
who who shot them it's actually pretty
funny too when you put so many of those
in a row oh here we go here's a Battle
Pack
so this is actually a regular uh Battle
Pack let's just open it anyway yeah so
you see on the screen on the right-hand
side these are different skins you can
get and how rare they are the ones that
are in a bit of a reddish orange oh no
sorry like Little River Edge brownish in
the background those are legendary and
the blue ones are also rare but more
common so we'll see if we can open those
once we get out of the load screen here
then the Barbarian is asking if uh
support's putting out enough damage uh
I've messed with supports weapons quite
a lot to be honest I think the best one
is the m1909s I like the storm variant
of it that thing kills dudes the other
ones I don't think are that good except
for the starting one the Lewis gun
um the nice thing about the Lewis gun is
I think it has a really good sight
picture I think it has good damage
output and it has a faster reload than a
lot of the other weapons plus I've just
discovered that if you're wearing your
gas mask
um
you can still put your bipod down so you
are the most accurate person on the
battlefield in a cloud of gas at range
which you think would be like all right
it's actually very useful though because
I can't tell you how many times the the
enemy team throws gas at you and they
think that your ability to shoot them
has been diminished but if you are
playing as support and you go prone and
deploy your bipod you are laser accurate
with the with the gas mask on yeah
because normally when you're standing
when you put the gas back on you can't
there's no weapon you can aim down the
sites with once you're uh gassed when
you have your gas mask on so that comes
really handy
all right so that's another thing too
about this game look I mean look at this
the maps are just they're so gorgeous
and it really kind of pulls you into
that conflict
um I know we've stated this before in
many of our videos and even in our live
streams but
yeah for us here this this is easily one
of the one of the best battlefields come
out in years aside from Bad Company Bad
Company uh two so it's definitely gonna
be worth your time if you're a
battlefield fan so this map on
operations has two blimps correct
uh you get to so when you're the
attacking team and you get held back
each match has three rounds if the first
round the defending team wins the second
round the attacking team gets the
Behemoth which on this map would be the
blimp uh the Zeppelin and then when if
we hold them back again the third and
final round they get it again and if
we're going back again we win the match
so so a good trick for this one is when
you start your unlocked tree
once you get your good first starting
weapon you should probably head over to
the vehicle section and pay attention to
the artillery truck
because the artillery truck you can
unlock the AAA Gun on it and that can
save your bacon on this map
yeah no that's that's definitely going
to be one of the best things to do for
this type of game
but hold on a second let me just
I highly encourage you want to talk to
your teammates but because we're doing a
live stream we can't do that here but
yeah definitely definitely communicate
with your teammates I know that's kind
of a hard thing to do in games like this
people have kind of become very silent
on their mics but for a game like this
and any type of team-based shooter you
really got to communicate guys like just
use those mics just say hey I need help
over here I need ammo I need help so
yeah actually unlike an hard line in
this game you cannot walk up to a
support player and just take ammo off of
them which I actually don't like wait
we're losing objective yeah
um so you have to still play a good
support player in this game if you play
support and you don't take ammo you're
not a good support player don't be that
guy yeah don't be that guy don't be that
guy and if somebody's shooting their
pistol at you that's the universal
Battlefield design for give me ammo or
if they're like jumping up in front of
you and you can clearly see that they
need help or they need something that
you can provide them just give it to
them all right here we go here's that
time to use that rifle grenade we did
have some questions about buying premium
should you do it I don't know I become
extremely wary of Premium between
Battlefield 3 and 4. I think if you buy
premium
you're basically saying
I like I I if you buy premium you're
basically saying I will like every DLC
after after this point even like I'll
I'll still be playing this game in eight
months and I'll still want to play that
DLC which I think is a fairly bold
statement because even people love
Battlefield probably won't buy the last
buy or play much of the last DLC like
maybe for a week and then why is that
worth it you basically just
paid a bunch more money for something
you didn't play so I don't know I'm not
not in a premium anymore this guy's got
the uh
hold on a second
of this thing
I think he might be out of my view range
oh no he's booking it he knows oh you
have the uh the mortar variant yeah the
mortar variant on the city the guy who
had it before I did he basically bailed
out of his vehicle to to capture the
thing yeah you don't need to leave your
vehicles to be near the flags to capture
them and uh yeah the fact they just did
that now the vehicle's mine and now his
team's basically down to vehicle so one
of the cool things about the mortars in
this game including the support class is
you follow the mortar visually as it
goes over the battlefield so you can see
everything under it and one of the
things the game doesn't tell you is that
you can actually fire mortars without
going back to the view of the person
firing so you can actually just use an
aerial view and do little manual
adjustments without the animation
completing and it's a good way to like
Drop two or three rounds on top of
somebody like if you get the first hit
that person might move you should
immediately fire again without waiting
for the animation to complete
this cannon
uh Buck is asking what are we playing on
we're playing on operations and what
console are we playing on we're playing
on Xbox one so
we've been playing on PC a lot lately
this is what it looks like on Xbox One
and
obviously gonna be some tiny differences
here and there but overall both both
games play really well definitely been a
a big fan of both playing it on PC and
on Xbox one it's also coming out for PS4
as well so hopefully we'll get a version
of that up sometime soon
come on come on I think this game
was probably in production a little bit
too late to catch Microsoft's cross play
initiative but that would have been the
sickest thing ever it would have been
really cool oh I got that guy maybe next
Battlefield all right well because I'm
not an engineer I can't really
although for your support you can Wrench
It Right unfortunately I'm a medic so
I'll put my team
there we go why would you stay in there
if you are a support you must Wrench It
yeah all right well you know what
because this wasn't our vehicle to begin
with I can abandon it so
that's another thing too to keep in mind
is that whenever you have a vehicle
that's belonging to your team and you
abandon it if it's so long as it stays
alive on the map it will still count as
a vehicle taking up that slot so if you
want a new vehicle in you have to
destroy it so don't just leave vehicles
that are about to uh they're low Health
just because you can't heal them because
as long as they stay on the field and
still in one piece they still count as
taking out that vehicle slot so this one
as you can see I'm not destroying
because that belongs to the enemy so
that's their vehicle
um nope's asking what Battlefield won't
have offline Bots not as of now no
that'd be really cool though I you know
everybody's sick actually because there
are times where playing on multiplayer
can be a little taxing uh it's nice to
kind of lay back and play against uh
Bots I mean it's possible but is it
coming out anytime soon no although
actually I don't know do you consider
the campaign Bots because then yes but
not multiplayer the campaign is amazing
I think the campaign will kind of
satisfy anyone's itch to kind of go solo
for a little while they kind of want to
take a break and also as a campaign is
really good for getting you kind of
warmed up ready to go for the
multiplayer in this game because
anyone who's not who's new to the
franchise or hasn't played in quite a
while but that's gonna get me that's
gonna get me yep yeah everyone hasn't
played any of the latest versions of
Battlefield in a while or kind of fresh
to the first person shooter area they
should definitely give the single player
a shot because the single player
actually surprising is pretty good I
can't remember last time a Battlefield
game uh single player was that much fun
to me because I know personally hard
lines was mediocre and the past of the
Battlefield games weren't too great and
simply a single player but this one they
kind of done a you see the war in
different perspectives
so that's always pretty cool
hello to Bob Jones who's joining the
chat
I appreciate the he's asking
oh he's commenting that we are pro
players my KD has never been above I
think 1.14 so if you find me on the
battlefield the chances of us killing
each other are about 50 50.
I do love this game
also the gun I'm using right now is a
late unlock for the medic class and
so yeah talk about some of the medic
weapons because I got to be honest I
really did not like the meta guns um
they're dmrs and I think they jump at
least the starting one jumps left right
in just the way that lets you miss a ton
what are your tips on the medic class
weapons the middle class weapons uh they
get better as you unlock them it's
probably the more streamlined class I've
run into to where every single upgrade
it gets better and better as it goes
along for the assault class right out of
the gate you have very powerful weapons
for the support class the starting
weapons are I think the best you're
gonna get and for the Scout class I
would say every single sniper rifle not
almost every single one can kind of hold
its own pretty well some are better than
others obviously but aside from that the
medic ones are pretty good so and by the
way oh there we go there's a whole
charge
549 is asking how long is the campaign
what was it like six hours it's a series
of vignettes so the campaign is a series
of several maybe five stories each story
has a couple of chapters in it and then
it moves on to another story there's
like an air campaign there's a tank
campaign
there's a uh yeah
there's a couple of sort of stealth nope
on foot sections of in in pretty much
all of the campaigns have a stealth foot
section
um it's just kind of like an overview of
world war one and I think it did a
fantastic job of telling personal
stories and getting you engaged yeah see
this is
exactly and this is also great too right
here because my team they're dropping
Health they're dropping out while
they're Reviving each other and
obviously in a game like this for
operations the more plays you have on
the flag the more you're gonna be able
to uh hold the position so we keep
Reviving each other and keeping each
other alive so
for me frizzell's is saying recon's the
best since they do the most damage with
their guns that's true there's actually
so they've actually put it in an
interesting mechanic in this game that
mirrors sniper rounds in real life the
Recon class does more damage at range
than they do up close which simulates
how the bullet like slows down and
actually drags through targets I would
actually recommend that playing as the
uh what is it the Scout class without a
scope or get used to using the iron
sights because the iron sights the
majority of the guns in this game
require iron size as you see here on
this gun so the more practice you get
the better off you're gonna be and you
can practice either with the
oh come on you can practice either with
the Scout class or with the meta class
they're the best ones to practice using
the iron sights on
um the other thing about the Scout class
in this game formerly Recon is the
bullet drop is almost nothing now and
bullet drop is very minimal at this
stage so it's actually
I think I don't know I hate to say it
but it takes a lot less talent to be a
scale player now than it did before
yeah I mean I think it kind of depends
on the rifle you're using so but overall
I would definitely say that it's become
a lot easier to snipe in this game but
at the same time too it's not it's not
as much of a pain to deal with I think a
lot of people have always been kind of
hesitant about snipers in this game
because in past Battlefield games anyone
who was a sniper like oh man they can
one shot kill me no matter what hit me
in the body in this game it's not true
uh you can actually really it takes
about two shots in the body and
obviously if you get a headshot it's an
instant kill but actually takes quite a
bit of practice to get used to sniping
in this game we had a question if
there's any sniper rifle that kills in
one hit I'm assuming you mean to the
body there's one immediately that's a
battle pickup
um I don't think we've gotten far enough
into the unlock tree
find if there's a sniper rifle there is
one extra standard bullets oh I got a
chance to play when I went to the uh La
events but it's not a one hit it's not a
one-hit kill no but it's pretty close
like if you get hit by this thing you
basically have to load in a bullet each
and every time you fire a shot it's not
like a bolt action it's literally where
you have to load in a shot every time
you pull the trigger and it does I would
say it could knock down about 80 of your
health if you hit him just straight in
the body and it's an insta kill on the
head but it's one of the last guns you
unlock for the
a scout class so I don't I can't recall
the name of it I got a chance to use it
for a brief uh period of time and even
so with all that damage I actually
wouldn't recommend using that gun too
much because you are pretty vulnerable
each and every time you fire that shot
even if you do hit your Target because
it not only does it sound amazing on the
gun but
yeah you did and I always sound amazing
on that gun but it's also it leaves you
very vulnerable so a good tip for people
who haven't played
too much Medic in the past
um is to heal make sure you heal
yourself a lot too
um you have ammo or sorry you have a
medic hacks well we we affectionately
call the smaller ones medic snacks same
with support they have the ammo like
create any ammo snack
um but if you get into a gunfight
um with the dmrs they're a little bit
tricky to learn how to use so what you
do is you get into your gunfight you uh
break off if you're gonna lose and you
heal yourself and you come back at 100
and re-engage the cool thing about that
is the health regeneration and
Battlefield 1 is much slower than it has
been in previous battlefields so you
actually have a pretty good Advantage if
you can heal yourself oh that was coming
at you these so these craters are
fantastic these craters are are like
largely dynamic in this game they don't
they're not there at the beginning of
the round and you can dive into these
and do some serious work
all right okay so now this was the first
round of three at this match we held
them all we held them actually on the
first they didn't pick the first second
no they didn't we're still in the first
sector so now
uh the attacking team is going to get
their Behemoth which will be the
Zeppelin and
this will happen to them once in the
second round and once in the third round
once you destroy it it is gone for good
for the remainder of that of that round
so you don't have to worry about coming
back it does take a lot of Firepower to
bring this thing down and most likely I
would say on average if you're even with
a good uh defensive team I would say
that a behemoth can possibly push you
back by two SEC uh two sectors but aside
from that don't don't worry about it too
much try to focus as much of your
Firepower on the supplement as you can
anytime people can try to use those A8
guns are scattered all over the place
try to use those as often as you can and
give your teammates who are using those
cover because those are primarily the
things you want to use to take this
thing down Bob Jones is asking if you
got a chance to use the Babe again you
have to be level 10 Scout to unlock it
so we haven't quite got there yet but
we've seen plenty of funny videos about
the baby I have been shot by it yeah I
was shot at it at the event and as cute
as it is and funny as it is it doesn't
do that much damage but still though
come the day that I get it I'm gonna
totally use it it's good for the lulls
that's about it I think getting killed
by that thing is pretty hysterical I
mean yeah if you get killed by that you
were probably just sitting there
laughing hysterically as you were
getting shot because other than that you
probably will not get killed oh there he
goes he's on fire
all right uh in the chat we're talking
about the martini Henry which is the um
level 10 Scout
weapon that's the one I think you load
in the top that you were talking about
you played it in the yes review event
right yes so it's still not a one-hit
kill
to the body
because it only it goes up to about what
90 and then there's damage drop off
well it's weird so like a lot of the
he's doing the dance under the gun
um so yeah again like a lot of the Scout
weapons the bolt action rifles they
actually do more damage at
at a specific range so maybe at that
specific range if you master it
it could be a one-hit kill if not to the
Head
um that's kind of The Sweet Spot people
are talking about right now in the chat
The Sweet Spot is the perfect range at
which
Scout rifles do their maximum damage not
the body location necessarily
yep we lost it so oh
yeah another thing too is that once you
take over a sector if you're the
attacking team any Defenders are still
in that sector get shown up all over the
map both on your mini-map and also on
your screen so for Defenders once the
sector is taken I know it's it's
preferable to try to take as many
attackers as you can but be be prepared
that they do know where you are now so
just keep that in mind if you want to
stay in a sector that has been lost
because they will know you where you are
every single time until you leave Mason
Venture is asking you on a scale of one
to ten how much do you like this game
funny you ask
um so our rating system is basically one
to ten and we gave it A9 um the official
score from Game Spot was a nine I as a
long time Battlefield player I'd totally
stand by that
um I think they have mastered the basics
of Battlefield in this game
I still think there's room for the
battlefield formula to grow but I think
this is a masterful version of a
Battlefield game
yeah and I I definitely agree with I
mean to me this is one of the best
Battlefield games to come out in recent
memory it definitely trumps hard lines
uh Battlefield 4 and 3 and to me
personally I still love Bat Company 2 a
little more
oh he's on fire
yes but is this game definitely a major
Improvement of the past three
battlefields easily hands down it's one
of the best if you have been dying for a
new Battlefield experience this is the
one to go for
coyote Stark is saying he doesn't really
want to pay twenty dollars to play the
game three days early you have a five
dollar option if you choose you can do
the like the EA Early Access 10 hour
trial which then your progress saves
over to your game so if you can't wait
another day you can pay five dollars
instead of twenty dollars to play Early
yeah and that's actually really I
wouldn't even say that's that's a pretty
smart move on EA's part because that
gives people a chance to because I think
they kind of realized that hard line and
even Battlefield 4 went out their
biggest successes there was definitely a
lot of problems with those so they're
kind of saying hey you know what if
you're still on the fence about trying
this game you know here's 10 hours I
mean you get to play for 10 hours you
get to play two single player campaigns
or part of the campaign and then you can
jump into multiplayer and anything you
do as you stated gets brought over to
the full version so if you fall in love
with your plan
holy cow yup see that's what happens
when you focus your attention Zeppelin
goes down it goes down and wherever this
thing lands oh boy you don't want to be
I don't want to be so
oh it's coming down on the Chateau oh
wow that's beautiful
[Laughter]
revive that man there you go buddy
uh so in the chat people are asking if
we want to talk about actual World War
one I will say this I'm not like I'm not
a big historian I think we do have some
people
um like Mike mahardi who love history
um but I will say that I think the
campaign did World War One Justice
there's actually some great moments in
the campaign oh that's weird there's
some there's some great whoa yeah
there's some great stuff in the campaign
about the futility of war and how
individual lives were meaningless I
think that's one of the reasons why they
chose to do what was it five stories
instead of one because if you're one
person you would have just been gunning
through all of World War One and killing
everybody but playing as multiple
protagonists basically let them make it
uncertain for you as to whether that
person
or people who they cared about survived
I think it's really cool too the fact
that you get it from different
perspectives of a war because for me
personally I love history but the fact
that you can actually play as you can
play as the Italians you can play as the
Australians you can go you can see from
different perspectives you can then jump
into uh you can then join up with
Lawrence of Arabia and get the idea of
how the war was over there in the Middle
East it was definitely
for me personally I love that kind of
stuff and I really like the idea that
they've paid attention to it and they
cared about the license that they were
working with
and I mean is this like dead on accurate
to World War one no I don't think so I
think a lot of these even the weapons
I'm pretty sure a lot of these weapons
were designed probably around that time
blueprinted but did they ever see action
we ever see combat I I don't know yeah I
kind of doubt it for most of these guns
the guns themselves and the weapons are
sort of fantasy world war one they're
things that would not have been commonly
used or ever used in World War One like
I think most World War one and correct
me if I were wrong but I think most of
world war one was both action rifles
still there were some bolt action rifle
conversions that were too expensive for
armies to use in in Mass to make them
semi-auto
um you did have the invention the
machine gun which was big but I think
most people died from artillery
yeah they I mean well I wouldn't I would
just say artillery I would also say the
mustard gas gas was so horrifying oh
that was pretty horrifying too that gas
was so horrifying there out on the uh
especially on the Western Front where
countless stroves of soldiers were were
killed but also deformed by all that gas
since it was horrifying to see on a
lighter note
Julian Salas is asking how do you get
Squad suppression kills this is funny
because I'm actually working on that one
right now that that
um trying to get suppression kills in
Battlefield 3 and 4 and Battlefield one
always drove me nuts because as a
support player you basically just have
to fire over a bunch of people's heads
and not kill them which doesn't make any
sense for your play style but if you
want to get suppression kills you
basically have to focus on wounding not
killing people and just play with a
squad who can who can mop up because if
you kill them I don't think you get the
suppression kills and that is to
basically unlock one of the challenges
that leads into your ranking system that
leads into your war bonds which lets you
buy weapons and tanks that's pretty
tough that's a pretty tough one to get
to be honest I don't I've never liked
that assignment I always thought it was
a bad thing to ask people to do I'm very
cognizant of a developer asking players
to do things that don't necessarily help
their team win because a lot of people
will do them to get the points and they
won't
put out for the objective so yeah not
I also feel too is that aside from other
Battlefield games this game really does
Focus heavily on teamwork
and also more importantly also too on
flanking because of the size of the map
especially in operations excuse me
especially on operations where the maps
are so huge like the sections are so
huge you can literally go anywhere and
they put kind of secret entrances into
buildings or certain ways like you could
actually go down in the basement of this
uh complex and come out right on top of
one of the flags so you really have to
be aware of your surroundings
and let's see if I can get this guy
there we go
Derby steps see that's why I want to
keep a bayonet because you never know
you'll have an opportunity like that
nobody got me hello to killer walk 11
over a Game Spot thank you for joining
us for anybody else who's just joining
us you're watching a battlefield 1
stream we're talking about tips and
tricks if you have tips and tricks feel
free to put them in the comments we've
played as most of the classes combined
uh we've been playing this game for
about a week now Spencer went to the
review events
um so yeah the rest of you're gonna get
this game who don't have some of the
premium additions tomorrow
then everybody can murder each other in
a nice World War one setting
that's always so nice
Yusuf is asking what's the strongest
weapon in the game
oh that's that's tough I think it's okay
I'm gonna cheat because actually I'm
gonna go into the um some of the battle
pickups or the elite classes there is
the I'm gonna have to look up the name
there's a sniper rifle that's basically
a tank hunting sniper rifle that you can
pick up and it not only murders any
player in one hit but it's we've seen it
shoot down airplanes in one hit
um and it can take down tanks in several
hits but it is so satisfying and if you
even don't even kill the pilot if you
even shoot the plane's engine it
disables the engine and the plane unless
until the pipe can heal the uh repair
the engine he can crash and get killed
that way too so
all right here we go although my
favorite new weapon in the game at least
in the beta was the horse I know the
horse is taking a bit of a Nerf which is
sad
um
but man I love the horses the horse is
so much fun
I mean it depends on the map it needs to
be a wide open map but getting saber
kills is probably one of the most
satisfying new things in this game I
guess oh no
all right okay everybody good
yeah as you can see when I have my all
right when I'm not getting shot uh when
you have your mask on you can't actually
look down your sights so until you take
the mask off
but actually one of the interesting tips
that we have for you is if you play a
support and you put your mask on you can
still go prone and use your bipod so you
you are more accurate than anybody else
at that range
oh you can also get a prone under the
horse Wing oh yeah we've experimented
with that too if you go prone when a guy
is taking a saber swing at you you can
actually get under the horse you know
what's interesting is that I was
wondering when I was the horse and that
little reticle you have with the saber
you actually have to be very delicate
with how you where you aim that when
you're Swinging with the saber in the
beta it didn't matter you could swing
that thing all over the place if you
were just in the same
I could say bubble of the enemy that
you're with that you're trying to get
with they will automatically get hit by
it but this they've changed it in this
and this one in particular for the final
version to where it's very very picky
where you're gonna swing and where
you're gonna hit so oh you're not doing
the thing that we all actually always
recommend people do too which is I guess
it's less important operations but
always be asking for orders always give
orders if you're the squad leader and
always ask for orders if you're not
because you will get
significantly more points for doing the
things that you were already doing
basically oh we're on fire we're on fire
oh boy yeah incendiary grenades
returning from Hardline actually there's
quite a few things in here that I feel
like were developed in Hardline such as
the incidentally grenades being able to
shoot airplanes with small arms fire
different types of melee weapons heavy
and light those all came over from
Hardline so even if that game wasn't the
biggest success I think that they took
some of the interesting developments
from Hardline and put them into
Battlefield one I mean you could
definitely tell they took some influence
from a lot of the old Battlefield games
but
I think I'll all came together
it came out I think really well done
yeah by the way this gun I believe is
called Next time we get a kill you take
a look at it Leo wants the game to give
some Canadian love maybe in a DLC maybe
I see no reason hey Rainbow Six Siege
had Canadians who are horribly horribly
overdressed for every other maybe we'll
do a Pokemon campaign the Canadians
played a part of World War One they'll
do a whole campaign about them yeah that
was that was the question
um I guess stay tuned because I don't
see a reason why they couldn't expand
into other other factions and other DLCs
oh man I got one Health the cool thing
is right now you're having a Close
Quarters gunfight but this map is huge
yeah no this is we're just trying to
hold off one part of a larger map so I
mean we're surrounded that's for sure so
we're not gonna
We're not gonna hold that one for much
longer but the object of this one is
that we're whittling down their
reinforcements because unlike say in
Rush when you take a sector or when you
take uh say two crates in Rush the game
automatically replenishes your
reinforcements and here it doesn't so it
may give you a few but not a lot so once
you take over a sector as the attackers
if you lost a lot of guys you're still
gonna be down a couple people so you've
got to be really making sure that you're
coordinating with your team to take
these flags quickly because if you don't
guess what you're going to be out of
luck here pretty quick Roman Center in
interesting question did you guys also
think they use the worst map for the
beta
um I thought Sinai desert was actually a
lot of fun the first beta was on Saint
Quentin scar which I thought was a very
safe map it wasn't the most exciting I
would agree
um it also depends on what mode you play
Same Quentin scar I think sane Quentin
scar on Conquest isn't is a is a very
safe but not super interesting map but I
think it's really cool on operations and
a couple other a couple other modes you
know I would actually I would actually
disagree I feel like that map in the
beta like it made me it made me excited
for this game but it didn't get me like
how do I say oh that's cool
of the flame tank yeah I mean like that
was awesome yeah but no I I just yeah it
didn't get me like I was excited for
Battlefield I was excited because I'm a
battlefield fan and I was like okay this
is fun this is cool but then once we got
a chance to at the event when I got a
chance to play on maps like this and we
got to play operations it changed
everything I'm like okay
this looks great this looks like fun
this is what we're going to be playing
and I can't wait for more I didn't get
that same type of feeling from the beta
but now that we're getting a chance to
play this it's it's amazing it's so much
fun and I can't wait for all you guys to
give this game a try
oh
by the way just let you guys know if
you're playing as a medic and you want
to level up quickly Reviving teammates
gets you a lot of points so take a risk
go out there save teammates lives also
this will it will help you guys
immensely when you're attacking keeps
the lines moving forward and defending
big time as well
also interesting to point out if you
take the hell snacks with you instead of
the health packs you can just throw them
at people directly so you target them
and then it auto hits them with it and
they get health right away there's
sometimes you'll see it like auto track
yeah I've seen one I could throw one and
he's like it follows him all the way
there I'm like all right that's a little
weird but I guess the job done you still
get the points all right so now we're on
the third round of this match and they
as you can see they get their Zeppelin
back I think we're gonna win this though
because
we took it down pretty fast the first
time but who knows they may hold us off
here another thing to keep in mind is
that when you're on the attacking team
and you're in the Zeppelin or behemoth
uh you shoot down I mean sorry when you
can bomb the AAA uh defenses once those
things are destroyed they're they're
gone for good I have not played around
yet where when they were destroyed they
spawned back uh I've seen players try to
take out wrenches to try to repair where
the turrets were but because there's a
fat Crater where those Church used to
stand they're gone for good so if you
are in that thing and you're piling it
and you see someone say using one of
these fly over and drop a bomb on them
and that gun will kind of be gone for
good so here we go this is also why it's
extremely important though to get your
anti-aircraft
um artillery truck
so yeah if you do find yourself fighting
a zeppelin or blind oh he's gonna get me
on this energy
one of them is a rigid and one of them
is a non-rigid and I forget which one
but if you find yourself fighting as
Evelyn
um as an AAA Gunner you target the
individual compartments underneath that
are shooting at you first because if you
take those down they can they can't fire
back at you so they do spawn back on in
the blimp uh but it buys you and your
team time to continue to open fire
because those guns up there can actually
tear apart infantry really quick so you
really want to focus on shooting those
parts off as soon as you possibly can so
as you see right here that's our tank
it's still functional so I'm gonna
destroy it because
yeah I want to respond so but oh man I
think there was a lot of damage there we
go also hello to the people in The Game
Spot chat we're taking questions from
both
um game spots
and YouTube oh no no no no
oh he went right before me too
uh it was funny actually I think in one
of the early Alphas there was a
prototype where you could jump on top of
the tank and throw a grenade in the
hatch and nobody was really sure if that
was intentional or not I'm a little
disappointed it's not in the final build
because I think it would have been Nifty
to let players do that yeah but I don't
know maybe the tanks went down too fast
Maybe
I would I want to save that guy but I
know their enemy is like
oh
got me definitely you know what I might
change up class here
so we can show some stuff here all right
so here we have the support Giovanni's
asking what motor playing we are indeed
in operations mode which is the new mode
to Battlefield it's sort of a
combination between conquest and Rush
maybe similar to Conquest assaults of
the past but on multiple sectors
frontline's fuel of War I don't know
it's a little bit of all those it's
right yeah yeah I would definitely say
it's it's a definitely combination of
conquest and Rush smashed together and
and but I think it takes the best
aspects of those modes it makes
something really cool now this is really
cool I love this as a support class you
can get uh different types of mortars
and some do damage uh better than others
but overall it's a really great uh
Loadout piece to do so let me just
actually this is again you were talking
about earlier the uh m1909 is my
favorite support weapon I think it just
kills people the best but it also
sacrifices a large ammo capacity so the
other one I've been using is the Lewis
suppressive right I started going
through all the other support weapons
like the bar and I wasn't really that
impressed so I'd recommend not spending
too much money on the guns up front in
support and when you can when do you get
the bar like what rank do you have to be
personal rank for the uh support class
before you get the bar I think the bar
is around three let me pull it up real
quick for you
um I'm still working my way to the you
know it just broke off right there I'm
sorry to interrupt down that yeah but
yeah so when you shoot down the turrets
like that it actually kills both the
people inside of it and it falls right
off it will spawn back eventually but it
buys you guys time to then take out the
other one and do some more damage on
this thing because we gotta bring this
down fast we're actually down to our
last
sector so to answer your question the
bar m1918 trench variant I do like but
it has one of the lowest ammo capacities
of all support weapons with 20.
um it's good on 1V ones but I don't know
you shouldn't really be playing support
for the one-on-ones you're supposed to
be laying down accurate bipod mounted
fire on enemies and suppressing them
although suppression is pretty minimal
so far in Battlefield one cool yeah you
can also disable the engines uh it buys
you it slows this upwind down take out
both engine it stops still right in the
sky so Julian Salas is asking how often
do you ban that charge so this is um for
people just joining us is one of the
things that we talked about earlier so
you can actually pull your bayonet off
of your weapon you have that choice if
you pull your bayonet off of your weapon
you shoulder your weapon more quickly
from a Sprint so how often do you
bayonet charge an enemy is up to you
it's up to your play style
um there are advantages to bayonet
charging such as it's one of the only
things that can one hit kill Elite
classes which is very important but if
you are not somebody who's finding
yourself bayonet charging very often you
should probably pull it off because
you're hurting your speed to bring up
your weapon from a Sprint in the whole
rest of the game all right we uh we're
down to our last base now
gotta take this thing out fast all right
we already got enemies showing up ooh
best meta gun we got a question for the
best mad again you play the most medic
what's your opinion
um that weekend I was just using I think
it was called the uh Auto reload I can't
think of the name right now but I was
gonna we'll go back to in a moment once
I die again so I hope I don't die
anytime soon but yeah that gun that gun
to me is one of my favorites it doesn't
have very high damage but it definitely
has a high rate of fire and I mean you
have to it's a single shot weapon but I
feel like I get the most bang out of my
buck for that gun so the auto loading
there's several variants the 8x35
factory the 8x25 extended
there should be one other one in here
all right let's take a look at it though
8 by 35 Marksman
and it is this one I I would say that
the starting
medic weapon is tough to handle so I
would at least recommend getting that
second one the m1916 factory it's a lot
more friendly and what's great too is
that you can actually oh what's
interesting too is that as you just saw
right there we can you can go in there
and do a slight customizations to your
guns we can still uh you can take out
the magnification of how long down the
range you can see you can also adjust uh
for some guns where how The Recoil
reacts you can have it instead of going
down the center it can have effect on
your left and effect on your right so
it's a little it's little tidbits here
and there it's not very deep
customization uh it's a little
disappointing about that because I know
a lot of people were looking forward to
really oh can I put a scope and I put
two mags on can I do that kind of stuff
but
for what's there it's it's it's okay
it's not amazing but it's definitely
something that I think kind of gets the
job done it's pretty cool Stephen is uh
in Cape Town South Africa he's saying he
can play in 12 minutes he's waiting 12
more minutes to play the game
well hey man good luck to you sir if he
jumps in go for operations they have all
the modes here uh too as well but what
we're playing here is operations and
every operations mode you jump into it
starts off in a cinematic uh fashion and
depending upon what side you're on
you're going to hear it in that
nationalities uh tone so keep that in
mind so if you join us the British you
can get a you're gonna get a British
narrative join the the Germans you're
gonna get a German narrator and that
through every single map so kind of it
puts more it makes you invested more
into the side that you're fighting for
so
and really good really good dialogue
really good script writing in this too
so we have questions in the chat about
customizing um without getting into a
multiplayer match
I would say this is one of the downsides
of this game you still can't do that nor
can you customize in between rounds but
you can use Battlelog which has just
released I think yesterday it's not
ideal but you can customize with
Battlelog on your computer or using the
mobile app in between rounds I think
yeah it's kind of industry standard
these days to let people do it in
between rounds so yeah but but still
it's to me that feels like kind of like
a I don't know I think that's Up For
Debate but yeah let's see here I would I
would Mark the game down on that regard
because I want to be tweaking my
loadouts all the time yeah so for those
of you who were asking about the
metagraph this is what I'm using right
now it's the auto auto loading 8.25
extended now the reason why I like this
one over the other is even though the
others have more damage actually in Hip
fire I'm looking at control for any of
you out there have been playing this
game uh the beta or even the early uh
trial version a lot of the meta guns
have crazy recoil so I like this one in
particular because it has the best so
far the best control out of the variants
of this gun why don't we show
customization too because actually I
don't want to just say everything's like
great in this game
um you know there we gave it a 9 out of
10. there are some things that I would
mark it down a little bit for I think
they kind of phoned in this
customization a bit for now you can
change I can change them two different
sites there's only two sites yeah you
can change magnification which I don't
even think conceptually makes sense but
that's cool from a gameplay perspective
and you can pull the bayonet on and off
and then on some weapons you can choose
left right or Center recoil but the
damage stats in the lower right corner
don't reflect
what any like indication of what you've
done
so I don't know the customization they
can definitely work on in the future
it's not there yet and you can
definitely tell that they focused more
on what they could give you in terms of
Firepower than they would on
customization which I think was nice I
think that's good but it was but past
Battlefield games have had quite a lot
of customization it's not there at
launch in Battlefield one so
I love the maps
um I love a lot about this game they
have some work to do on weapon
customization now this was the gun you
were talking about earlier for your
support class so let's give this one a
whirl it doesn't have very good damage
but it's also got really good control
this guy right here is using the mortar
I'm actually join him a bit to use ours
because we're on the defensive so that's
the other thing too is that depending
upon how the outcome of a match goes we
uh since we lost we are now in uh we are
now defending in a different part of the
map now but this can basically
continuing down our multiplayer story so
this is actually what happened to the
Germans in World War one where they lost
that battle and they got pushed back to
the Argonne Forest so this is actually
part of history the history play out
like this uh that's Up For Debate but
this is where this is the closest you're
gonna get so it's actually kind of cool
that how you progress in operations is
how it happened in the war and if you
say win a battle that in history your
your faction lost the game actually
tells you a narrow heard of well if they
had one we think this is what would have
happened so that's pretty cool it's
little details like that that I think is
pretty cool Leo actually has an
interesting question about heavy
artillery being in the final build
um so there's one thing in Rush that
kind of counts as heavy artillery in
Rush mode the defenders in Battlefield 1
can arm the crates too
technically it's not harming the
greatest when they arm the crates they
call in artillery and any
attackers who are spotted by your team
can potentially be killed by artillery
strikes so if you're playing Rush make
sure if you're on the defending team you
are both arming your own crates for the
artillery strikes and spotting people to
get hit by it other than that though the
only the next closest thing is the
support class has a high explosive
mortar that's marginally effective
versus Vehicles yeah and the other thing
too is that since it takes time to rank
up individually for your different
classes I've noticed that when you play
in rush and you use that if you go to
the crate and activate that artillery
strike on targets that have been spotted
and you get the kill you get a truckload
of points like I I actually ranked up
pretty quickly playing Rush a few times
for getting my support not my support my
salt and my meta class up pretty quick
all right so
nope the Empire second fire yep okay
kills this
hey he was like right on top of you
you got me right there yeah I was I was
smart for you to deploy that in the
middle of the open
yeah no it's
I'm enjoying everything about this game
really to be honest with you it's
there's definitely some a lot of
shortcomings on it but in terms of just
sheer fun I really have not had any bad
moments in terms of multiplayer to me
and anytime I get killed in this game
it's it's my fault you know like on some
games where you get killed it's like oh
that person killed me because they had
you know the Homing rocket or a trace
bullet or they had something special
that they used no in this if you die
it's because hey I made a mistake I
should have you know what she was saying
I should have ducked I should have done
this I should have done that so you have
to play Smart in what you choose to do
although we did have that one
interesting moment
during the week where you fired a rocket
at a
tank at a very steep angle and it
bounced off
yes
um and we had to go look up whether that
was intentional or not I know like I
recognize this has happened to other
people including YouTubers and they also
had to go ask the developers so the
answer is
um that it's intentional and this game
if you fire your rocketed tanks at a
steep angle there's a risk that the
rocket will just bounce off the tank
which is kind of interesting
it's interesting but it kind of sucks
when you're in the in the middle of a
fight you're trying to take it down a
tank and you're shooting like it
ricochets off because there's really no
warning of that it just happens
sometimes so it's it's weird so but
um yeah overall oh boy
Matt's asking if there's any uh sounds
like body specific damage uh no not not
in Battlefield one
like you can't get
winged um
it's not it's not as specific as like
ARMA or a game like that
oh revives thank you oh nope yeah
we have people in the chat eagerly
awaiting the countdown
we're within five minutes of them being
able to play the game in Central Europe
they're dying for it because
I can't blame them like this game is
this game is awesome three minutes three
minutes and Counting you can then run
around in the Argonne forest and
kill each other
oh that guy just fired up
oh that was actually kind of smart Okay
so the one actually the one one that
we're still experimenting with is the
flare on the Scout so there's two types
of flares that we've played with so far
there's a blinding flare which is
actually a lot of fun and then there's a
regular flare which will set people on
fire and spot but we're still kind of
experimenting with how the spotting
Works whether it's
line of sight whether it's active as
soon as it flies or whether it's just
kind of Airy effect right come on
so there's a few things that we're still
experimenting with but
um anybody who didn't join us earlier
um
we've been playing this game for about a
week now it just opened up I think about
three days ago for early enlisters there
was the Early Access trial for 10 hours
um
and then tomorrow is when everybody else
can get into it which is actually in
three minutes for Europe apparently
also too is that if you have the extra
war bonds and you like playing a support
I recommend getting the ammo crate that
way not only yourself but your teammates
get ammo too and it doesn't disappear
because if you use those little packs
the moment someone picks them up either
you or a teammate it disappears so
you're going to want to make sure that
you have that so let me make sure I get
that equipped
there we go
hello to in-game instincts over GameSpot
oh we're gonna flanked yep we're gonna
flank
suski wants to know what price you get
the game for or you can't get the game
for I don't know I've played battlefield
for a lot of years my personal opinion
is don't buy premium editions yeah wait
wait to see what happens just by
standard edition and don't do it and get
your enjoyment out of it because there's
a very good chance you won't buy the
last DLC eight months down the line
anyway and it's actually just like a
good deal for you to buy individual DLCs
yeah and then kind of
I think the last time I bought a Premium
Edition was on Battlefield 3 and I
regretted it after a while because not
only did my friends and I kind of
stopped playing it after a while but it
just when you think about down the line
it's like wow I just wasted was it 50
bucks or so on some added DLC that
frankly half of it was good the other
half was terrible so if you're a super
fan and you know it then and you have
the money for premium then go for it
um but it's not necessary at all
all right we're whittling these guys
down
so
yeah up here comes the gas so Julian's
asking about um
barbed wire trenches digging holes we
can dig holes with uh bombers and tanks
if they blow up there's some real big
holes that happen in this game uh no
barbed wire ability although I don't
know it kind of seems like something
that
they could add in as a class ability
later on for one of the classes it would
actually make a lot of sense to have
barbed wire
oh I think that's a point throw a guy
right
digging trenches no but there are a lot
of trenches in this game there for you
oh flamethrower guy right here oh and
you're the one class that does not have
a bayonet charge you're gonna die there
you go
um you can you can bayonet charge Elites
and kill them in one hit
Zachary saying it's sad how premium
splits the player base my problem is how
premium splits the player base literally
like later on when premium players have
the game and they have new maps in
rotation players who don't have premium
physically cannot join that rotation so
I hope they fix that in this one
um because I do think it splits the
player base and that's a missed
opportunity and I think in a way Rainbow
Six Siege was very smart nice work with
the way that they did DLC to let
everybody always play all the time and
not split the player base so yeah I'm
not gonna defend premium in four seconds
I think
I think the idea of Premium started off
okay but then somewhere down the line
very quickly after I think they mess
with premium it got out of hand like
paying 50 bucks for
promised DLC pretty much like oh hey you
know trust us we're gonna get something
out there you're gonna enjoy and it's
gonna take about a year for all of it to
come out but yeah go for it uh yeah just
I don't know it didn't function well
with me at all so it's it's nice to know
that you don't need premium to enjoy a
game like this
um and I think in past
the past Battlefield games you can buy
the DLC separate so if there's something
in the DLC coming along that you like
but you don't want to buy the whole
thing I think you can buy it
individually so I'm kind of hoping they
do that for this
the first map is also free for
pre-orders I believe and it's like you
can't not pre-order the game for the
most part so there's at least one
they've done this every Battlefield
where there's one map that everybody
gets up front
which is good
all right let's see how we did
do you want to try a round of rush let's
do a round of rush let's do a lot of
rush I want to show people what's up oh
flag Defender cool show people how Rush
is a little bit different right this is
the screen that annoys me to no end
because I can't do anything while I'm
here other than look at my stats well
it's also too is that when we were
playing on the other map
um
I wish I wish it combined everything you
did like all your kills all the deaths
and everything you get like an overround
like overall look so I mean you can view
it somewhere but it would be nice if
they can bind it but yeah at least this
is operations so
I mean I would say operations is one of
the most unique modes although actually
I haven't played messenger pigeon
pigeons I thought you were the first
time you're kind of sounding well you
are sending a message so that's pretty
close the first time you told me about
war pigeons I actually thought you were
joking no I wish I should open a bow
pack yeah
I mean a war pitches it has its moments
it's fun it's it's a keep away match
I'll try it so it's
up up
I opened it but yeah yeah we can view oh
so we can view it here so I have 660
let's open up an enhanced
uh Battle Pack why not see what's in
this thing
keep me that hot
create opening animation
so here we go
I love that somebody dice was like man
it'd be so sexy if we could just have
this great crate opening animation let's
let's make
that looks way too fancy nah that was
not worth nah you got a fancy pants yeah
distinguished for a gun that's gonna
take me a while to get to and I'm gonna
scrap it you can you do have the option
to scrap these things at any time it's
not just where oh I take it now but I
change my mind later you can always
scrap these at any time so you're not
permanent so these are the legendary
melee weapons we were mentioning earlier
so now you get puzzle pieces and once
you collect five puzzle pieces I'm
assuming that's when you can get to use
this thing as you can see I have one
puzzle piece so far and you get these
puzzle pieces by opening battle packs
now if you don't want it you can then
scrap it for 270 uh scrap pieces so it's
up to you you can choose to do that okay
I actually would like to switch the
defending team I can so
that hurt a little inside I have that
gun that would have been real fancy
pants on my gun that would have been
would have been cool for you
but not today
we had an earlier question as to whether
people could bring over their
um
what is their icons from battlefield for
not just your dog tags your actual the
one that you drew I'm not sure I don't
know about that
you should uh I haven't found it yet but
I will say that by the end of
Battlefield 4 99 of those were butts so
you can just leave your butts at home I
don't need you drawing butts in my kill
cam
it makes you just want to kill them more
though
it was like 99 butts
people people got really creative with
shapes and made butts out of things I
didn't even think were possible all
right so one quick little note here
about being in the light tank which is
this little guy here uh to me he's this
is one of the best uh tanks you can you
can run around with
mostly because of the fact that it has
two different firing uh variants it has
the one the regular tank shell which is
one I have a quick right now then
there's the one where it's kind of like
a shotgun shell so
this one's perfect for hitting that tank
if I can slow him down oh we had a
question earlier that I totally didn't
answer they asked um how do you get to
the bomb sites on plane it's actually
just
switching to the bomb and then at least
on Mouse it's just right trigger gets
easier bomb sites
I kind of stopped using bomb sites after
a while though I think you're better off
just kind of eyeballing it from third
person there's a guy right here yep
yep because they get to sites and out of
sights is a couple of button presses but
if you learn to eyeball it in third
person
it's a lot faster
I love this thing this shotgun shell
like it this is the great like
anti-infantry killer
didn't even know I was there that's
funny oh hello yeah tank right there
uh nope read a lot of time when this
thing's kind of brutal so uh we I mean
we did have a question about trenches
and
um craters and such craters appear in
this battlefield dynamically as things
explode which isn't in my mind is
pretty incredible like that wasn't there
before your tank blew up because the
craters get used as cover I mean you can
you could probably intentionally oh you
got the cowboy gun you should people
this yeah no this is this is pretty cool
so this is actually
uh yeah the this gun actually is really
cool it's the pepper M1
m1893 this is actually looks like a
western style gun it's basically it kind
of looks like a revolver I guess it's a
revolver rifle so you guys can say that
with this so it's pretty cool I really
like this gun so the assault the
artillery truck is great too for taking
down the Zeppelin or any type of
aircraft because when you go into your
customization options you can actually
buy different upgrades you can either
you can attach a mortar to the truck or
an anti-aircraft uh Cannon also on the
truck because I highly recommend when
you want to take down aircraft
especially when you're playing in
operations this is the go-to vehicle
when you need to take down a zeppelin
very very quickly you need to take down
bombers too I'd go as far as
recommending you invest in some of the
armor unlocks before you bother with
guns too much because it's more useful
in more scenarios once you have a good
gun for class I'd stick with it and
spend your money on or your war bonds on
grenades and action in tank and plane
variants for a little while
oh nice job see yep right there
Jesus he's got one too
Leo's asking what do you guys think
about the tank pilot Cavalry classes
um I don't think it was worth them
getting rid of the engineer although the
assault just is the engineer to make
those individual classes
I've got mixed feelings about them on
one hand there's far few people stealing
your airplane to fly to some sniper nest
and just wasting your airplane which is
a big problem in other battlefields
on the other hand
like you used to be able to level the
class you were playing with no matter
what vehicle you were driving
and when you choose those classes you're
just leveling that class
so I don't know jury's out I kind of
have mixed feelings about those
individual
I mean it makes sense as to why they did
it uh because they wanted to kind of
they wanted to kind of congest them a
little better but
yeah I could see where you come from on
that
asking are all the vehicles historically
correct
um or artistic license I would say the
majority of them are but in terms of
their speed they're not accurate at all
I know that that trench that giant
trench tank that thing was slow as hell
three miles per hour in real life yeah
which was it's like a walking pace it
was it played a part in the war but did
they play a significant part not to a
lot of people's knowledge oh ooh flat
Cannon most of the weapons of vehicles
in this game are
future World War One
so they would not have appeared in any
numbers if at all in World War one
because they were either blueprints too
expensive for militaries to buy or just
came into development later in the war
um or their handling characteristics are
way better than they would have been
during World War One so
based on history but taking a lot of
creative license yeah so now we're going
into the Scout class here now this is
the flash flash gun this is awesome I
love this thing this thing can blind
your foes and if you hit them with it
which I tend to do a lot you light them
on fire The Grooming the groom of the
stool is saying horses weren't that fast
until at least the 50s
oh my God
my God yeah tanks at that time were
unreliable they were only one about
three miles an hour
fun historical fact they had a lot of
rivets in the tanks yeah so that thing
for example that goes way too fast and
the rivets would actually kill people
inside the tanks when they would get hit
by shells it was a bad design and they
were super hot and and you would not
have been wanting to be in one you
wouldn't want to live very long in that
thing
let's get up here
I'm pretty sure this reticle didn't
exist either
or this site on this gun we had a
question
um we had a question about is flying
hard so it's interesting in the beta I
thought flying was super easy they've
done something I can't quite put a
finger on it they put more weight to the
plane I feel like it takes a lot harder
to to turn yeah the Turning slower in
the full release maybe they'll dial that
back the attack the attack plane I mean
you have three different types of planes
you got a bomber and uh you got the you
got the attack flame which is good for
fires and then you got the kind of
universal plane that can kind of attack
anything around both ground and air
um and for me aside from the fighter
variant the the other two they're really
it takes a long time to turn on those
things so especially when you're dog
fighting it takes a it takes time
getting used to that all right these
guys are right over here
I would say though compared to other
battlefields the planes are more
friendly because
they're slower they handle a little bit
better
than planes in previous battlefields
which were fast and quite frankly I
think planes in Battlefield 3 and 4 were
pretty disconnected from the ground game
whereas I feel like these planes are a
lot more grounded in a similar fashion
to the helicopters of three and four
right
although I don't know I love the world
war one theme I will always miss
helicopters though helicopters are the
best
helicopter is pretty fun but I think for
what they have here I think they've done
a pretty good job I'll have to settle
for horse
we don't have a helicopter for you but
let me give you a horse
here we go
um Andrew's asking what's a good class
for beginners to start with
I would say assault for sure yeah
assault assault for sure because
um they're the one you they're the more
uh Universal type of soldier and I think
they can kind of handle almost any
situation anytime you have an enemy
vehicle jumping on you you have
basically two weapons to take out a
vehicle with machine guns are pretty
good and of course you got the shotguns
I would then say next play as a medic
and then move on to support then I would
kind of save Scout for last because as
fun as it is for those bolt action
rifles and they're so powerful
it takes time to use them it really does
it takes a while to do it to be fair
again they've gotten rid of a lot of the
drop in Scouts so it's easier to be a
scout player than it was previously in
Battlefield but yeah assault is probably
the least
the one you don't have to team play as
much with because you're not required to
give other people anything as assault
you just basically go forward kill
things and you've got all the
anti-vehicle weapons
um so yeah although Battlefield is a
game about team play so once you master
that you should start to play as Support
classes like supported medic because
they make a huge difference in this game
right
also too is that if you guys have any
mode you want us to try you want to
continue playing rush or go back into
operations or try something new for you
to let us know we'll be happy to jump
into that got a question about how the
guns are whether they're well optimized
or if you get destroyed if you start now
how do you feel about that I think the
guns just what you said we actually had
this conversation I think the guns are
well balanced between classes and each
class has only specific weapons unlike
previous battlefields where there were
carbines to bridge the gap
but I don't feel like the classes have
that much variation within them so I
don't feel like it's worth wasting too
much time just unlocking every gun
within a class I think once you have a
good gun you'll know it and you don't
really have to experiment too much so
no you won't get destroyed I think
there's good guns in every class
except for starting his medic is pretty
hard actually I'm not gonna lie I think
that starting DMR is pretty rough yeah
so maybe don't start as medic yeah the
starting medic stuff is tough but once
you do get past that that kind of bridge
you things do cut to uh look a lot
better for you so
so now we're uh we are defending so
while I guess asking what weapons does
each class start with
um you start with the trench I know that
the assault class starts off with the
trench uh machine gun that's what I
think he's asking about classes of
weapons so assault has the SMGs and
shotguns support has their more
traditional light machine guns medic is
restricted to dmrs which is an
interesting and I don't know how I feel
about that choice I think you've been
having a really good time with it yep
Scout has so far Scout has only both
action rifles I don't think they have
anything
[Laughter]
bad weapon
yeah use those field guns too man
oh he's got a flamethrower left flame
variant man I'm telling you if anything
I think what you might get stomped by
are people who have bought the better
tanks and better airplanes like the tank
killing airplane is a it's an airplane a
light airplane that fires freaking tank
shells
yeah the thing too though is that don't
be discouraged if you're jumping this
thinking oh man people have already been
playing this for hours and hours with
that early enlistment stuff I don't
think I'm gonna stand a chance that's
not true the weapons that you start off
with uh are they the best no but you can
still hold your own you could still do
what you can and get the job done
so see if you can um yeah I'm doing it
right now so when you come down one of
these objectives you can call down a
transformation ah that was a mortar that
was a mortar so we saw right there is
I'm trying to call in coordinates so
anytime that you or your teammates have
uh spotted enemies when you call in a
artillery strike at these uh crates at
these uh radios they will drop in an
artillery strike and anytime you get any
kills with that you get tons and tons of
points it's actually pretty ridiculous
how quickly you get these points all
right they're making we had a request
for the baby gun unfortunately you have
to be a level 10 Scout we're not quite
there yet
um but it's a pistol that you unlock at
level 10 as Scout and you can buy it
it's hilarious mostly useless weapon but
I recommend you it's pretty useless but
it's so funny to use you did get to use
it in the battlefield review event which
was kind of cool
I was shot at it I was being shot at but
so far so and it really didn't I got hit
five times and then I turned around the
guy was trying to reload and I hit him
with the hit him in the face with that
melee weapon and killed him but it was
it was pretty hysterical
um so far I haven't found any hidden
guns in this game you know hard line in
Battlefield 4 both had some
um pretty had some secret challenges we
haven't found one of those yet
I wouldn't be surprised if they did them
though
man that flamethrower tank just started
showing up today he's a space League
showing up everybody right now all right
we gotta fall back
uh we had a question about graphics on
Xbox one you're looking at it
this is uh we're playing on Xbox One
currently yeah I played it on PC as well
is the PC version uh a little bit better
yes it's pretty gorgeous yeah it's
pretty great but from what I'm seeing
here the Xbox One's no slouch either and
we're not gonna get you're not gonna get
some of the best visuals this game can
show but overall it gets the job done
pretty well all right so hopefully I
don't die again so in rush you can now
arm the crate as a Defender which sends
in an artillery strike yeah
spot that dude
we'll see if it
we'll see how it does
the thing that I noticed the most on PC
oddly enough was sand for some reason
the sand just just very granular and
like gorgeous and you notice that
because you actually spend quite a lot
of time in in oh let's see what happens
you spend a lot of time in craters
that guy's asleep at the horse
yeah no kidding
I definitely weaken them a lot though
can't answer the question about HDR
being supported
I know that that's something they're
trying to bring to
the PS4 Pro potentially Scorpio
I do know that it just I think it looks
gorgeous in general I was not impressed
by Battlefield 4 and I'm impressed by
how this game looks it's the first game
in a while I don't know outside of like
Uncharted
that I've been just genuinely stopped
and looked at things
while I was playing
yes this team's getting pretty pretty
wrecked
we got a question about how many hours
you put into it I gotta look it up so
far we've each put about a week into the
game although I haven't had a chance to
play every day
you know this seems getting right you
know let's go back to uh operations
let's give that one to that another
whirl
yep for that
do what you need to do man yeah I think
I think it's better that way I think
like I said people have seen Rush
they've seen Conquest wanted to tell you
guys about what you can do for that uh
radio call in but overall operations I
think is where it's at I think that
Mode's what's going to
really add to the longevity of this game
and it kind of shows the best it has to
offer as well
we have a question over the Gamespot
chat is this the biggest Battlefield
ever or still baby sets compared to
Battlefield 2. the claim was that some
of these maps are the biggest Maps ever
although
I go too is such a classic though I
think was the biggest one in three was
bandar Desert I believe
this would be the ultimate test
um was banned our desert so I don't know
like I will say this a lot of these maps
are large a surprising number of these
maps are large I remember Battlefield 3
had a N4 had
several maps that were small Close
Quarters maps and they've managed to
pull some of that off in this game on
large Maps which is what I like in
Battlefield
okay we're gonna do one more round and
then we're gonna wrap up here and so I
know we have Europeans currently
frothing at the mouth to go play the
game it should be starting to go live
there now according to everybody in the
chat
um any last tips and tricks or questions
you have about the game we'll get them
in this round and then we're gonna go
ahead and sign off
but was Maps one of my favorites this
one you actually are fighting in the
mountains so that's
definitely an add-on for any of you out
there who love
the kind of more Majestic feel of
battling up in the Alps and the snow
even though there's no snow but pretty
close
yeah the Ops map is actually one of my
favorites it's a it's like a mile or two
miles long yeah no it's it's pretty big
hopefully when we get there
the loading screens
better than the loading screens in four
I'll tell you that I think I timed one
of them at three minutes one time and
that was to get into the test server no
yeah no that was pretty crazy like test
Island it took me three minutes to load
into it all right looks like oh we're
all right
it seems on the final push so we're
gonna do a couple more minutes into this
operations map and then we're gonna go
ahead and sign off wish everybody in
Europe the best of luck getting into
their Battlefield games I'm sure you're
gonna enjoy it as well
favorite weapon so far we have that
question earlier I'm gonna cheat on that
one my favorite weapon so far is the
anti-tank kit it's a giant like 50 cal
sniper rifle you pick up that you fire
from a prone position that can down
airplanes in one hit or disable
airplanes in one hit and murder anybody
you shoot it at wow that took out a
large portion of the map
all right that's what I'm telling you I
mean if you're not if your team doesn't
focus on taking down that
that Behemoth quick it could be a real
nightmare for you and your defending
team so really type of you got to
coordinate you got to work with people
all right we gotta
all right bring it home Spencer
into the Alps
I like the fact that a lot of these
operation and Rush Maps do have very
distinct sections which was
a throwback to Bad Company
they feel they they actually go through
they tell a story
as you go which is cool I mean this is
ending in a fort it definitely did not
start in Ford it started it started down
in the mountains yeah went through
bunkers and then ends in a fort
come on
foreign
things asking can you play this game on
your own yes um you know it's you know I
would say even more so than
other strategic games just because
there's 64 players in a match
um
people in Battlefield well it does skill
match but people in Battlefield are
generally pretty good at
playing their roles giving ammo out and
health out and
um you could have an impact on this game
as a solo player although less than you
can do some of the 40 person matches you
probably have more of an impact
and Rush which are what are they now
like uh what's player count for Rush uh
I think it's 24. 24 so you can
definitely if you're a really good
player you can have a big impact on a
rush match
whoa
all right they're right above us
yeah this is their last base so they're
gonna fight whether they got now so
but once we capture this flag it is over
and this is the last sector of something
like five sectors so this map is really
long yeah no it's actually pretty tough
to get to this part of the map I think
some of these operations can last 40
minutes
you had them yeah pulled the trigger and
nothing happened
I blame the gun
you're the last battalion
I will say this looks like a very nice
vacation destination
you know once they clean it up a bit
of the debris and all that stuff once
they get rid of all you know the the
bodies and stuff
we gotta get them
it's funny this is because it's a World
War one setting because there's grenades
I keep finding myself wanting a trophy
system from other games that blocks
grenades yeah but there's no way you
could conceptually
have that in this game
although Scout does have a um like an
iron plate they can put down but it
probably won't stop grenades
Leo's asking what do we think overall
the game I think it is a
finely honed and well-crafted
Battlefield game
I think Battlefield is a franchise that
still has room to
try new and creative things Beyond
sort of being masterful at what it does
but I think this is one of the best
baffle games that I've played
in quite a long time
it's definitely it's one of the best for
sure
I'd honestly love it if Battlefield
in the long run would take some pages
from PlanetSide
and have three factions fighting and
uh a mode with an open world that you
fight between areas
um that would be interesting to see for
a Battlefield game yeah like I think if
Battlefield wanted to really take some
huge chances they could do that but I
think as a Battlefield game this is one
of the most finely honed and well
crafted Battlefield games I've seen in a
long time
all right we're down to our last
30 guys so if we don't pull this off
soon last battalion standards the last
30 guys yep um you know what's kind of
cool actually about the end of these
operations too is it gives you a little
bit of narration at the end to tell you
what would have happened if one side
what they think would have happened in
the real war if one side had won or lost
oh this is the uh oh this is the sniper
off you were talking about this is my
favorite sniper rifle in the game I
think it's gonna do much work here but
yeah you need to be this is not only
need to be bipod deployed to use it so
probably will not do too much work this
could on the other hand though sawed off
shotgun that might actually come in this
is one of the elite classes
I like that the guy's shooting through a
window there's actually a surprising
number of Windows and Doors you can open
and close in this game and there's even
ones you can lock which is pretty
hilarious
he was gonna try to ban at me but I got
my buddy so
appreciate the hello
I forgot gotta be prone on that one
somebody saved you
you were killed by space all right
all right we're down to nine
damn
oh no
it's gonna be really close yeah if
you're uh also if you're enjoying the
stream over at YouTube gaming
um feel free to like subscribe let us
know if you enjoy these sorts of streams
we've been streaming Battlefield all
week up until launch we love doing this
and if you do too let us know
also feel free to check out more of our
features as well we've done a lot of
stuff covering Battlefield and we
continue to do more uh as the months go
on up guy got me
you did all you could
one can only